qu'est ce que tu fais juste ce qu'il
faut et ils vont prendre qui sent et
puis m'enlève toussaint puis ils m'ont
rajoute d'autres vers eux qui puis après
ça je me sens mieux
mathias et matteo doivent aller à
l'hôpital tous lés cinq semaines pour
suivre un traitement
les appelle ça les change
transfusionnelle c'est ce qu'on fait
parce que dans le cas de max on lui
enlève 80 types de sens pour lui
remettre un 30 minutes de lait sans
qu'on le sent par contre qu'on reçoit
zilina lors des transfusions des jeux et
puis après ça a vraiment il peut être le
feu les enfants âgés de 7 et 9 ans sont
atteintes de l'anamis falciforme une
maladie héréditaire du sang qui cause de
fortes douleurs chez ceux qui en
souffrent matteo a été diagnostiqué à la
naissance son confrère lorsqu'il avait
15 mois moi je savais que je devais
porter mais on ne savait pas produit
avec de temps à autre qui avait tout en
mal on comprenait pas pourquoi il
pleurait beaucoup comme bébé et puis
c'est comme ça à mon âge été voir son
pédiatre pour savoir ben voilà il ya des
douleurs qui bique du c'est pas normal
et c'est là qu'on a su qu'il faisait là
ni faty forme je savais pas avant le
traitement qu'ils reçoivent toutes les
cinq semaines fait toute la différence
pour eux médaille d'honneur des
communautés noires ne sont pas nombreux
et c'est ce serait plus bénéfique c'est
plus facile de trouver la combativité ce
fait mieux si on prend du sens de déco
notamment parce que les gens qui ont la
maladie sédunois fait que c'est pour ça
que bon on a besoin je te merde de cette
génétique là c'est pourquoi héma-québec
redouble d'efforts pour avoir des
donneurs issus de ces communautés
deux au moins d'un minimum de 300 mais
c'est aussi au delà de ça parce qu'on
voulait commencer on commence par des
biblistes aplomb comment des petits
participants mais pour vraiment nous
amener à les avoir que tu es ne serait
ce que dix mille 15000 à 20000 donc par
année de la communauté ce serait
vraiment l'idéal pour le moment' et les
enfants ils prennent des buts
ils n'ont pas des grosses quantités mais
plus on vieillit plus on en a plus on
avoir de besoins
donc c'est pour ça qu'on encourageants
d'un courage on encourage les gens à
donner parce que ça fait ça a changé
notre vie ici diana quand ça laissera le
canada montréal